Imagine as soon as you sit down
in front of your TV at home,
your phone instantly
shows you what's
on your favorite channels.
Or as you walk up to
your daily bus stop,
your phone tells you that your
bus is delayed 20 minutes,
but you can take
the express instead.
Or perhaps you have
hearing difficulties
and need specific accessibility
assistance at your bank,
but instead of having
to spend the first five
minutes explaining this to
the employees, as usual,
they're already aware of
it and ready to serve you.
As a developer,
the key thing here
is having more
context so that you
can provide a better
user experience
and in fewer, or
no steps, at all.
Hello, I'm Timothy
Jordan, and this
is Developing with Beacons.
A common beacon that you'll
recognize is a lighthouse.
This simple but
important technology
has helped ships navigate
safely through busy shipping
lanes and dangerous coastlines
for hundreds of years.
Today's technology provides
us with a new type of beacon
whose underlying
concept is the same,
but otherwise looks
a lot different.
For one thing, instead
of a large tower
with a gigantic
spinning light, they
look like this or this
and this or even this.
And they can last for
years on the same battery.
But, more importantly, when
you use Google together
with your beacons, you get
an open and flexible beacon
standard called
Eddystone as well as APIs
that allow you to register,
manage, and detect beacons.
Let's take a look at how all
these components work together.
Say you've got a great
idea for using beacons
to improve user's lives.
A service that helps
commuters with public transit.
It's an app that detects
bus stops and train stations
and provides up-to-date
information concerning
their favorite routes
at those stops.
You'll first need some beacons.
One for every stop and station.
Several beacon types will
work, but we recommend one the
supports Eddystone, which is
a new open format for beacons
that anyone can use.
It offers a common
format to build upon
and a means of extending
it to include new features
and use cases.
And it does all of this in the
open on GitHub under the Apache
2.0 license.
Now these beacons
work with both Android
and are already available
from six manufacturers today.
Once you get your
hands on a beacon that
supports the Eddystone standard,
you'll need to provision it
and then, depending
on your use case,
you'll want to register
it with a cloud service
and attach data.
Provisioning is simple.
It just means specifying
the basic beacon settings
such as the Eddystone frame
type, the transmit power
and the broadcast rate.
Your beacon manufacturer
should have instructions
about this process and
they're likely to have
either an app or APIs
available for this step.
Now some beacons even come
pre-configured for you.
Once provisioned, your beacon
can start broadcasting itself
to the world.
If you're employing a physical
web beacon with the Eddystone
URL frame type, you set the
URL in this provisioning step,
and you're done.
For all other
frame types, you'll
want to register the beacon
and perhaps attach some data.
Registering happens with
the Proximity Beacon API
by providing basic information
such as the beacon advertise
identifier, status, whether
it stays in place, like a bus
stop, or moves around like
an actual bus, a place ID,
a lat-long, and a
few other fields.
This step also enables
various Google integrations
like the places API and
the nearby API, which
we'll talk about in a moment.
Finally, you can use
the Proximity Beacon API
to add some attachment data.
This is where things really
start to get powerful.
You can add attachments that
will have a namespace, which
corresponds to your project
ID in the developer console,
a type, which is a string
that specifies what kind
of attachment this is, and
is unique in the namespace,
and 1K of data.
You'll notice by
the sample data,
that it's enough for some
strings or even some JSON,
but you wouldn't want to
start encoding JPEGs in here.
One last thing on the
Proximity Beacon API,
you can also use it to
manage your beacons at scale
by detecting lost
beacons or low battery
and performing
activation, deactivation,
and decommissioning.
Watch for these APIs to
mature with your feedback
over the coming
weeks and months.
OK.
Now you've got a
beacon that just
sits around broadcasting its
ID to anyone who will listen.
Well, truth be told, it's going
to keep broadcasting its ID
whether anyone is
listening or not,
and I can't decide if this is
incredibly noble or perhaps
sad.
But let's just
call it dedicated.
Next, we'll need to set up our
app to listen for our beacons.
We could write our own service
to scan for the beacons using
Bluetooth LE and then look them
up with the Proximity Beacon
API, or we could let the
nearby Messages API do
all the heavy lifting for us.
I'd recommend the latter.
First, you'll subscribe to
Messages from the nearby API.
Included in this subscription
is our Transit Project Namespace
since we're only interested
in those beacons.
Nearby then keeps an eye
out for these beacons.
When one is sited, it grabs the
beacon's information, including
attachments, turns
them into messages,
and passes them
over to your app.
Now that's it.
We've now got working
beacons and an app
that uses them to make the
awesome happen for our users.
Beacons are all
about adding context
to the world, whether
at a specific place
like your favorite
store or moving around
like a food truck.
With this context, you
can provide an experience
for your user that requires
fewer steps while being
richer and more accurate.
We have excellent
videos and documentation
on all the different aspects
of these platforms and format.
Check them out for more
details on each and to get
started adding context
to all the things.
Thank you
[MUSIC PLAYING]